[Music]
chris is with us in albuquerque
albuquerque new mexico hey chris how are
you
hey dave how are you thanks for taking
my call and thank you for fixing stupid
and stupid as me so thank you for that
well we've all been there brother what's
up
yes sir so um a tragedy has put me in a
position to buy a house that i know i
can't afford
with you know um
twenty percent down with the fourth or
mortgage in the fourth of my income so
right now i'm 21
um i make 74 000 a year
next year that'll go up to 90 000.
i have 80 000 saved um
this house is worth two hundred and
ninety four thousand probably i'll be
buying it for 294 thousand it's worth
about four hundred and forty thousand
so i'm wondering do i just put down the
twenty percent
which is 58 000 or do i kind of go more
aggressive and
wipe out my savings
with why i guess accept a thousand
dollars and
get my mortgage as low as possible
i do want to do a 15 year i don't want
to go 30
but what do you do for a living
i work in procurement and pretty much
government contracts
for a national laboratory
okay i missed the part where a tragedy
helped you i don't understand okay so
one night it didn't help me by no means
um my uncle passed away five months ago
or five months ago yesterday
and so
i'm kind of the only one in the position
to buy a house and my my family wants to
keep it in
and by no means of the forest i've been
taking care of the house for a couple
months and i absolutely love it
i just don't i don't know so the family
wants to sell you a house that's valued
at 440 for 300.
for yes sir 294. okay where did the 294
come from
that is what my uncle owed on the house
so
that's that's what they're saying before
okay why
because they wanted to stay in the
family that badly
um yes sir is there an obligation on
your part to never sell it
um
no
um is it on family land i don't think so
it is not unfamiliar i know sir okay
so what happens if you uh get married
and your new wife doesn't want it and
you sell it
is everybody in the family mad at you
that is a possibility however i don't
think so
i think realistically
my mom would actually probably downsize
and get into it um
you know they they're very emotional
they're holding on to just about
everything um
and she had made a comment i can't get
into the house i'll pass
this is a trap
your families your families your family
is whacked
this is a trap you're 21 years old
this is a trap you're going to regret
this because of all not because of the
math but because of all the emotions
tied to it you're going to get painted
into the corner and you're going to get
paint on your feet somebody's going to
be pissed at you when you try to do
something nice and you strain your butt
off at 21 to do it
well it's my goal so i've been living
here since a month after it taking care
of it and at first you know i felt
pressured but after these couple months
i know you're gonna feel pressure when
you want to sell it and somebody wants
to buy wants to buy it from you at a
deal
well don't i don't necessarily know if i
want to sell it my goal is to pay it off
no you're going to want to sell it
someday
and when you do somebody's going to be
pissed if you don't give them a deal
inside the family
yes sir there's that expectation on this
there is you know i'm right
no i i they're gonna bring up the fact
that they gave you a good deal
chris let me ask you this if if your
uncle had not passed away in this house
situation didn't come your way would you
be looking to buy a 294 000 house if
this hadn't happened right now well
when when he passed i was in a totally
different position like i said i was
stupid and then i found i found dave
five months ago i was about sixty
thousand dollars in debt i sold
everything got myself a hoop deep paid
off my student loans now i'm completely
debt free with eighty thousand who are
the uh who are the heirs
your mom my mom and my ass
my mom and her sister okay
they have to write you a detailed letter
that says you are free to do with this
house
anything you want any time you want
without asking anyone's permission
you are not obligated to give them first
route of refusal you are not obligated
to give your cousin a deal your cousin's
dog a deal you're not obligated to do
nothing
if you buy this house it is yours to do
with as you dad gum well please forever
and ever and no one is allowed to say a
peep about it that needs to be in a
letter
i agree with that 100
but i think i don't think they can do
that
because you've already got it my mom
will move down into it if i want to move
you've already got all these backup
plans and all these side angled things
and that's what's scaring me here
i mean
i say that i mean they live in a house
all of us have moved out that's the only
reason why she would
but but they're very emotional people
you just said too
yes you've already let too much escape
out of your mouth to backtrack now no no
yeah i'm not trying to backtrack uh
sure you are you got used to the
pressure you admitted you got used to
the pressure initially there was
pressure and i don't think you would
have been in the market for a house this
expensive at this age you're 21 you're
in great shape i listen here's the
here's the way i want this laid out if
you keep it a year and sell it and make
five hundred thousand dollars profit
nobody says beep
yes and if that is the case
then do the deal
then do the deal yeah yeah you can do
the deal but put everything down but an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses not everything but a thousand
dollars so everything everything but
fifteen thousand dollars
and then if you get in trouble do not
hang on to this house in the name of
family emotion you sell it
just sir sell it
if you get in trouble it's a stupid
house
is it an issue going 15 years because no
put it on a 15 year fixed rate put down
65 000 keep 15 000 in your account but
you and your mama and your aunt all
better be emotionally prepared to cut
this thing loose because you are getting
into an emotional trap and i'm afraid
the trap is going to destroy you not the
deal
okay you hear my concern loud and clear
no i do and i i
i thought about that and that that is an
issue yeah i mean the number of times
man in 30 years that i have talked to
wonderful people like you and your mom
where your aunt gets so pissed off she
can't breathe because jim bob her third
cousin didn't get a deal on the house
after she gave you a deal on the house
and it was an unwritten set of
assumptions and you know what an
assumption makes everybody
that's what happens
and you got to have you got to have real
clear on that in writing it's not a
legal binding contract but it's them
saying out loud you are free to sell
this house 20 minutes after you buy it
and make a profit and nobody gonna say
beep
chris chris you don't have that freedom
yourself emotionally and they won't give
it to you emotionally relationally
please yes walk that's right
because chris needs a you need to
emotionally prepare yourself that you're
not going to get this letter i'm with
dave if i was i don't think they can do
it i don't think they can either i don't
think you're going to get the letter so
you got to be prepared for that yeah i
think because i think they're going to
want to hold it over your head this is a
game these people play man and it's just
i can smell it
man there's crazy in every family and it
takes all kinds of different forms be
careful and i'm not saying your mama's
crazy i didn't call your mama crazy
don't get mad at me
but i said it could be
could be the ant it could be jim bob and
it could be jim bob's blue tick hound i
don't know but somebody in that pile is
going to cause a mess i'm just saying
and i'm just man i've spent so much time
in rooms with people that everybody's
mad and
it has nothing to do with the financial
transaction it has everything to do
there by a set of assumptions
and that's a real
you're 21 man you got a big wonderful
life ahead of you
don't screw it up with your uncle's
house